look
[Music]
how are you greeting jaramillo comes out with his
brief industrial news in
spanish another economic wave and returns
to nevada to help build
businesses the check protection program
was aimed only at small businesses
the program will open for
all  businesses after the funds promise to
help merchants with their expenses and
retain their employees until the end of
march
pay close attention if you are looking to take
the cobi test 19 taxi station will
start offering car
service on wednesdays thursdays and fridays
starting at 8 a.m.  in the morning you
do not need an appointment and the test is free
of charge this site will ask for information
on your medical coverage but it is not
necessary and an audi and carmen steinert
will also continue to offer the test and
will ask for your insurance information
remember that the information will be to
recover  the cost of the test
through your insurance only the
national guard cook county and district
or health of southern nevada will continue to
operate the effort the
governor's new plan separates the community
into two categories
frontline workers and the general public
most residents within this
category will receive the vaccine
through a pharmacy workers
ringside will be vaccinated the site is like a
boyfriend uas touring high school the
health district is planning a
mega vaccination center later this
week at the convention center and the
cast message the clark county school district will
consider
a plan tomorrow  To return
students to the classroom
, the educators' recommendation is to create a
small plan individually addressed to each
campus. The decision comes after a new
report that the majority of
students are in trouble with
online learning, yes, it is, and
revealed that  students in 90%
of schools received an efe in
rating compared to
last year several parents tell us
that they are not surprised with the
results after the lack of personal interaction i
heard this delta airlines
joins others in banning
emotional support pets the company advised
that only professionally trained dogs
will be allowed and their
owners  they will have to check documents
alaska american and united also
recently changed their policy
many today will put their luck to the test
since the profits of the tractor tree are
at 550 million dollars
nobody won the mega mailing prize
last night and this increases the amount
for this friday  at 750 million
dollars
this would be the fifth largest win
in lottery history and now we
take a look at the temperatures in
our region a sunny day is expected
with temperatures in the 60s it will
increase temperatures for the
next few days the end  during the holiday week
there will be light winds and again the
cold will return to the  zone have a
nice day bland and salt and jaramillo and this
was x now in spanish happy wednesday
[Music]